Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode involves a crime against children. It may not be suitable for all listeners. It was a scorching hot morning on Monday, February 22, 1993, when married couple Ron and Dina, not their real names, drove along the brand highway towards the small western
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。本集涉及针对儿童的犯罪。可能不适合所有听众。那是1993年2月22日星期一的一个酷热清晨，一对化名罗恩（Ron）和迪娜（Dina）的夫妇驾车沿着布兰德高速公路（Brand Highway）驶向西部一个小型城镇
Australia town of Grenf. Ferocious salty winds from the nearby coastline were once again lashing the dry countryside, the same winds that had left some eucalyptus trees along the flood plains permanently bent at a 90 degree angle. These leaning trees were just one of a few attractions that Township had to offer, but it was far from a tourist destination. Located 400km north of the city of Perth, few at the time would have even heard of Grenf, or have any reason to visit the quiet and sparsely populated sheep and wheat farming
格里诺（Grenf）。来自附近海岸线的强烈咸风再次猛烈吹打着干旱的乡村，正是这种风使得洪泛区沿线的一些桉树永远地弯曲成了90度角。这些倾斜的树木只是该镇仅有的少数几个景点之一，但它远算不上一个旅游目的地。这里位于珀斯（Perth）以北400公里处，在当时，很少有人听说过格里诺，也没有什么理由去拜访这个安静且人口稀少的绵羊和小麦农业
community. Ron and Dina knew the area well, having spent time there with their friend Karen McKenzie. Karen resided in Grenf with her three children, Daniel, Amara and Katrina. The 31-year-old single mother had recently gotten together enough money to rent a small house on the rural outskirts of town, where landmarks and homesteads were few and far between. Their modest, cream-coloured weatherboard house stood alone among the windswept wild grass, partially framed by dense bushland.
社区。罗恩和迪娜对这片地区很熟悉，因为他们曾和他们的朋友凯伦·麦肯齐（Karen McKenzie）在那里度过了一段时光。凯伦和她的三个孩子丹尼尔（Daniel）、阿马拉（Amara）和卡特里娜（Katrina）一起住在格里诺。这位31岁的单亲妈妈最近刚刚凑够了租金，在镇郊的农村租了一座小房子，那里的地标和宅基地相距甚远。他们质朴的乳白色木板房孤零零地矗立在饱经风吹的野草之中，部分被茂密的灌木丛环绕。
At the isolation of the area, Karen was working hard to build a good life for herself and her kids. Ron and Dina had set out for the McKenzie property that morning to help Karen with some home repairs. They drove along Grenf's main street before turning down Georgina Road, a long, unmarked stretch that cut inland between acres of paddocks. Soon, Ron and Dina reached the turnoff to the McKenzie property and pulled up to the house.
由于该地区地处偏远，凯伦一直在努力为自己和孩子们创造美好的生活。那天早上，罗恩和迪娜出发前往麦肯齐的住所，去帮凯伦做一些房屋维修。他们开车穿过格里诺的主街，然后拐入乔治娜路（Georgina Road），这是一条长长的、没有路标的路段，在数英亩的牧场之间向内陆延伸。不久，罗恩和迪娜到达了通往麦肯齐住所的岔路口，并在房子前停下了车。
They could hear the family's pet dog barking wildly from inside the house. But other than that, everything was eerily quiet. The wind batted several lines of washing strung up in the backyard, but there was no movement from within the house, and nobody came out to greet them. The state of the house seemed inconsequential to what Ron and Dina spotted upon arriving. Someone was lying motionless on the driveway. It looked like Daniel, Karen's 16-year-old son. Assuming the teen might be playing some kind of prank, Ron got out to see what was going
他们能听到这家人养的宠物狗在屋里疯狂地吠叫。但除此之外，万籁俱寂，诡异得出奇。风吹打着后院挂着的几排洗好的衣服，但房子里面没有任何动静，也没有人出来迎接他们。与罗恩和迪娜到达时看到的情景相比，房子的状态似乎微不足道。有人一动不动地躺在车道上。看起来像是丹尼尔，凯伦16岁的儿子。罗恩以为这个少年可能在搞什么恶作剧，便下车去查看
on. Ron called out for Karen, but there was no reply. He tentatively walked towards the person lying in the driveway. As he got closer, a wave of horror washed over him. From inside the car, Dina became hysterical and screamed for her husband to get back in. Ron ran and leapt into the driver's seat, slamming the door behind him. He grasped the wheel and pressed his foot down on the accelerator. The couple sped off back down the driveway, leaving a cloud of dust in their wake.
情况。罗恩大声呼喊凯伦，但没有任何回应。他试探着走向躺在车道上的人。当他走近时，一股恐惧感席卷了他。坐在车里的迪娜变得歇斯底里，尖叫着让她的丈夫快回到车里。罗恩跑过去，跳上驾驶座，在身后砰地关上车门。他紧紧抓住方向盘，一脚踩下油门。这对夫妇沿着车道飞驰而去，在他们身后留下一团尘土。
The closest neighbor was a few hundred meters away. Ron parked on the road, jumped the fence, and raced towards the house, frantically yelling and waving. But nobody was home. He did the same at the next property, but no one was home there either. Ron rushed back to his car and sped up the main gravel road to the first house he came across, only to find that it too was empty. The couple then headed to the closest business, the Grenif Museum.
最近的邻居在几百米外。罗恩把车停在路上，翻过篱笆，朝着房子跑去，一边疯狂地大喊大叫一边挥舞手臂。但是家里没人。他在下一处房产也做了同样的事，但那里也没有人在家。罗恩冲回车里，沿着主砂石路加速开到他遇到的第一座房子，结果发现那也是空的。这对夫妇随后前往最近的商业场所——格里诺博物馆（Grenif Museum）。
Ron rushed in and asked to use their phone to call the police. He needed to report a murder. Although he suspected the body on the Mackenzie's driveway was Daniel, he couldn't be sure. The person was so badly maimed that their face was unrecognizable. Although Grenif is considered to be a bit of a ghost town, the major city of Geraldton is just 24 kilometers north. As the largest city north of Perth, Geraldton has many features that put it on the map, including a thriving fishing industry, stunning spring wildflowers, and sprawling surf beaches.
罗恩冲进去，要求借用他们的电话报警。他需要报告谋杀案。尽管他怀疑麦肯齐家车道上的尸体是丹尼尔，但他无法确定。那个人被残害得太严重，面目全非。尽管格里诺被认为是一座微型鬼城，但杰拉尔顿（Geraldton）这座主要城市就在北面24公里处。作为珀斯以北最大的城市，杰拉尔顿有许多让它名声大噪的特色，包括蓬勃发展的渔业、迷人的春季野花和绵延的冲浪海滩。
Near 60 kilometers offshore are Pelsart, Easter, and Wallaby Islands, key locations of the deadly Batavia shipwreck, covered in episode 138 of case file. For many travelers, Geraldton is their main destination, with isolated towns like Grenif acting as stop places along the way. However, in the late summer of 1993, Grenif would surpass the city in making headlines. The unassuming and little-known township was propelled into the national spotlight for what came to be called one of the worst crimes in Western Australia. For that reason, Grenif was put on the map.
离岸大约60公里处是佩尔萨特岛（Pelsart）、复活节岛（Easter）和瓦拉比岛（Wallaby Islands），这里是致命的巴达维亚号（Batavia）沉船事件的关键地点，案件档案第138集对此进行了报道。对许多旅行者来说，杰拉尔顿是他们的主要目的地，而像格里诺这样偏远的城镇则成为了途中的中转站。然而，在1993年的夏末，格里诺在登上新闻头条方面将超越这座城市。这个谦逊且鲜为人知的小镇被推到了全国聚光灯下，成为了后来被称为西澳最严重罪行之一的发生地。正因如此，格里诺才真正为人所知。
It had been a typical morning at Geraldton's Criminal Investigation Bureau on February 22, 1993, when detectives received news that a brutalized body had been found outside a residence in sleepy Grenif. Forensic Inspector Bryn Jones and Detective Murph Cousins, along with a team of uniformed officers, immediately made the 16-minute drive down the Bruce Highway, arriving at the Mackenzie property around 11am. As reported, a blood-soaked body lay in the dust just outside the homestead, having been so savagely attacked that their face was indistinguishable.
那是1993年2月22日，杰拉尔顿刑事调查局（Criminal Investigation Bureau）迎来了一个典型的早晨，当时侦探们接到消息称，在沉睡的格里诺的一处住宅外发现了一具惨遭虐杀的尸体。法医督察布林·琼斯（Bryn Jones）和侦探默夫·库赞（Murf Cousins）以及一队制服警员立即沿着布鲁斯高速公路（Bruce Highway）进行了16分钟的车程，于上午11点左右抵达了麦肯齐的住所。正如报道的那样，一具血迹斑斑的尸体躺在宅基地外的尘土中，由于遭受了极其残忍的袭击，其面部已经无法辨认。
The victim was identified as 16-year-old Daniel, the oldest of Karen Mackenzie's three children. Her other two children, daughter's 7-year-old Amara and 5-year-old Katrina, were nowhere to be seen. Karen, too, was missing. The detectives turned their attention to the house before them. The family's pet dog continued to bark from within towards a rear door. The detectives were rattled, was Daniel's killer still at the scene. When willing to take any chances, they raised their handguns before entering the property.
死者被确认是16岁的丹尼尔，他是凯伦·麦肯齐三个孩子中的老大。她的另外两个孩子，7岁的女儿阿马拉和5岁的女儿卡特里娜，不见踪影。凯伦也失踪了。侦探们将注意力转向眼前的房子。家里养的宠物狗继续从里面对着后门吠叫。侦探们感到震惊，丹尼尔的凶手还在现场吗？为了以防万一，他们举起手枪进入了住宅。
Nothing could prepare them for what they found inside. The lounge room was in complete disarray. Among the clothing and other items that had been strewn about, Karen Mackenzie lay face down on the floor, her head covered with a blood-soaked blanket. It was clear that she was deceased, having sustained numerous blows to her head and body, similar to those unleashed on her son outside. She'd also been positioned in such a way that indicated she had been raped post-mortem. The detectives continued deeper into the house.
没有什么能让他们为里面发现的一切做好心理准备。起居室一片狼藉。在散落各处的衣物和其他物品中，凯伦·麦肯齐面朝下躺在地板上，她的头上盖着一条血迹斑斑的毯子。很明显她已经死亡，她的头部和身体受到了多次重击，类似于她儿子在外面遭受的袭击。她的摆放姿势也表明她死后遭到了强奸。侦探们继续往房子深处走去。
Upon reaching one of the bedrooms, they found the bodies of 7-year-old Amara and 5-year-old Katrina, like their brother and mother before them, both had been hacked to death. Amara had also been sexually assaulted. Across the country in the state of Queensland, Evelyn pressed the phone receiver to her ear. She had lost count of how many times she had dialed her sister Karen's phone number, but each time the line rang out or occasionally beeped to signal it was engaged. Earlier that day, Evelyn had received a word from her brother who had overheard some shocking news on the radio.
走到其中一间卧室时，他们发现了7岁阿马拉和5岁卡特里娜的尸体，和他们的哥哥及母亲一样，两人都被残酷杀害。阿马拉也遭到了性侵。在昆士兰州（Queensland）的另一头，伊芙琳（Evelyn）将电话听筒紧紧贴在耳边。她已经数不清自己给妹妹凯伦的电话号码拨过多少次了，但每一次都是长音或是偶尔发出占线的哔哔声。那天早些时候，伊芙琳收到了她哥哥的消息，他无意中在收音机里听到了一些令人震惊的消息。
A woman and her three children had been killed in Greenough. Although the victims weren't named, their ages correlated with that of Karen and her three children. Interstate, all Evelyn could do was try to reach out to her sister via phone and hope for the best. But as her calls continued to go unanswered, her fears increased. She went out with her husband, setting the television up to record the news while they were gone.
格里诺发生了一起妇女和她的三个孩子被杀的案件。虽然受害者没有被点名，但他们的年龄与凯伦和她的三个孩子相吻合。远在跨州，伊芙琳所能做的只有试图通过电话联系她的妹妹并祈祷一切顺利。但随着她的电话继续无人接听，她的恐惧与日俱增。她和丈夫一起出了门，在他们离开时把电视设置成录制新闻。
When they returned, they watched the footage. The quadruple homicide making waves in Western Australia was reported, but the details were scant. At this point, Evelyn had no reason to believe the victims were her sister, nephew and nieces, but her instincts were telling her otherwise. Her husband contacted authorities to get answers. Evelyn studied his expression as he made the call. When tears started to fall down his face, her worst fears were confirmed.
当他们回来时，他们观看了录像。西澳发生的这起四重凶杀案得到了报道，但细节十分稀少。此时，伊芙琳没有理由相信受害者是她的妹妹、外甥和外甥女，但她的直觉告诉她并非如此。她的丈夫联系了当局以获取答案。伊芙琳在他打电话时注视着他的表情。当泪水开始顺着他的脸颊流淌时，她最担忧的恐惧得到了证实。
Evelyn later stated, I still remember that as clear as day. Nothing can ever prepare you for that moment. Inside the Mackenzie House, the juxtaposition was confronting. On one hand, the grisly scene was a living nightmare. On the other hand, it was full of all the small details that make a house a home. Toys were scattered throughout, drawings by the children were displayed on the fridge, and to-do lists captured the family's daily life. A Christmas wish list from Katrina assured Santa that she had been a good girl who hoped
伊芙琳后来表示：“我至今仍清晰地记得那一天。没有什么能让你为那一刻做好准备。”在麦肯齐的房子里，这种强烈的反差令人震惊。一方面，这个可怕的现场是一个活生生的噩梦。另一方面，它又充满了让房子成为一个家的所有细枝末节。玩具散落在各处，孩子们画的画展示在冰箱上，待办事项清单记录着这一家的日常生活。卡特里娜的一份圣诞心愿清单向圣诞老人保证她一直是个好孩子，希望
to receive a troll doll, rollerblades or a radio for her bedroom. Karen had proudly held onto a handmade card from Amara that wished her a happy Mother's Day. It was clear that they were a loving and warm family. But things hadn't always been easy for Karen Mackenzie. As a child growing up in Queensland, she had a great curiosity for the world and how things worked. She loved nothing more than exploring outdoors and was eager to learn everything she could. But when she hit adolescence, this curiosity led her to experiment with the drugs, and at the age of 15, she unexpectedly became pregnant.
能收到一个巨魔娃娃、轮滑鞋或是一台放在她卧室里的收音机。凯伦自豪地保留着一张阿马拉亲手制作的卡片，上面祝她母亲节快乐。很显然，这是一个充满爱意和温暖的家庭。但凯伦·麦肯齐的生活并非总是一帆风顺。作为在昆士兰州长大的一名儿童，她对世界以及事物如何运作有着极大的好奇心。她最喜欢的就是在户外探索，渴望学习她所能学到的一切。但当她进入青春期时，这种好奇心引领她开始尝试毒品，并在15岁时意外怀孕。
Karen gave birth to Daniel and was determined to make it as a single mother. She moved out of home and rented her own flat. But the challenges of young parenthood were overwhelming. Karen feared she couldn't give Daniel the life he deserved, so when he was two years old, she made the difficult decision to let her mother have custody of Daniel full-time. She then made the move to Western Australia. Years later, Karen fell in love with a man named Andrew Allen, and they had Amara and Katrina. She adored her two girls, but her relationship with Andrew didn't last.
凯伦生下了丹尼尔，并决心作为一个单亲妈妈坚持下去。她搬出家门，租了自己的公寓。但年轻父母面临的挑战是压倒性的。凯伦担心自己无法给丹尼尔应得的生活，于是在他两岁时，她做出了艰难的决定，让母亲全权抚养丹尼尔。随后她搬到了西澳。多年后，凯伦爱上了一个名叫安德鲁·阿伦（Andrew Allen）的男子，他们生下了阿马拉和卡特里娜。她深爱着她的两个女孩，但她与安德鲁的关系并没有持续下去。
Once again, Karen found herself as a single parent, but this time she was older and wiser and committed to making things work. She moved with her girls to Granef and reached out to her now-teenage son, Daniel, inviting him to come and live with them as a family. He agreed, and Karen was beyond excited. She was thrilled to have all her children living under the same roof for the first time. It would also give her a bit more independence, as Daniel was also old and responsible enough to babysit his younger sisters.
凯伦再次发现自己成了一个单亲妈妈，但这一次她更年长、更明智，也坚信能把生活过好。她带着女儿们搬到了格里诺，并联系了她现在已经十几岁的儿子丹尼尔，邀请他来和他们一起作为一个家庭生活。他同意了，凯伦兴奋不已。她很高兴有生以来第一次所有的孩子都住在同一个屋檐下。这也将赋予她更多的独立性，因为丹尼尔已经足够大且懂事，可以照看他的年幼妹妹们。
Daniel was equally looking forward to the change. For his birthday, he asked his grandmother for a bus ticket to Western Australia and made the move the following day. While Daniel had never really enjoyed school and often didn't attend, he enrolled at high school in Geraldton and gave it his best. Things had been looking bright for the Mackenzie family, and they had plenty to look forward to. For the family of four to be viciously struck down in the midst of building a vibrant and positive life together made very little sense.
丹尼尔同样对这个改变充满期待。为了过生日，他向祖母要了一张去西澳的长途汽车票，并在第二天搬了过去。虽然丹尼尔从未真正喜欢过学校且经常逃学，但他还是在杰拉尔顿的高中注册并付出了最大努力。麦肯齐一家的生活曾经看起来一片光明，他们有很多值得期待的事情。这口四口之家在共同构建充满活力和积极的生活的过程中遭到残酷杀害，这实在让人难以理解。
Inspector Bryn Jones turned to his team and said, I don't care what we do, but we must find the person that did this. The major crime squad arrived in Grenf from Perth and had to work fast. The sun was blazing down on the crime scene, and the accompanying strong coastal winds risked disturbing evidence. The team spent the remainder of the day and night painstakingly combing the property, determined not to let anything go unnoticed. It was an exhausting task, both mentally and physically.
布林·琼斯督察转身对他的团队说：“我不在乎我们做什么，但我们必须找到做这件事的人。”重大犯罪调查组从珀斯赶到了格里诺，必须抓紧时间工作。阳光正炽热地照耀着犯罪现场，随之而来的强烈沿海风威胁着要破坏证据。该团队花费了当天剩余的时间和黑夜，一丝不苟地对这处房产进行搜查，决心不放过任何蛛丝马迹。这是一项令人精疲力竭的任务，无论是精神上还是肉体上。
The crime scene was one of the most brutal that attending officers had ever seen, causing several to become physically sick. Others would later change departments or leave that sort of police work entirely. All would struggle with the memories of what they witnessed that day. This extreme reaction offers an explanation as to why the specifics of what happened at the Mackenzie house have been withheld. Deemed too traumatic for public knowledge, a rare court-issued suppression order has banned the exact details from ever being reported.
犯罪现场是出席警员所见过最残酷的现场之一，导致好几名警察当场呕吐。其他人后来调离了部门或彻底离开了这种警察工作。所有人都将与那天亲眼所见的记忆进行痛苦的抗争。这种极端的反应解释了为什么麦肯齐家中发生事情的具体细节被隐瞒了下来。由于被认为对公众而言过于创伤，一项罕见的法院颁布的禁止令禁止报道确切的细节。
The information presented in this case file episode is collated from the widely publicised facts. Three days before Karen Mackenzie was found murdered, she had attended a house party in Geraldton. Daniel had agreed to babysit his two younger sisters, affording his mother a rare and welcome to night out. The party was held at a friend's home, and according to some guests, it was relatively uneventful. Karen returned home at around 5am on Saturday, receiving a lift home from a friend.
本案档案节目中呈现的信息是从广为人知的事实中整理出来的。在凯伦·麦肯齐被发现遇害的三天前，她曾去杰拉尔顿参加了一个家庭派对。丹尼尔同意照看他的两个年幼妹妹，这让他的母亲难得地享受了一个受欢迎的夜晚外出。派对是在一个朋友家里举行的，据一些宾客说，派对相对平静。凯伦在周六凌晨5点左右回到家中，由一位朋友开车送她回家。
A neighbour happened to witness Karen's friend driving away from the house on Saturday, but they didn't see anything suspicious over the following hours. The family was targeted on Sunday night. Karen was asleep on a mattress in the lounge room when she was struck. Her daughters were then confronted in the bedroom. It was unclear how Daniel's body came to be outside, though some speculated he'd fled from the house and was chased down by his attacker, before being fatally struck in the driveway. The murder weapon was nowhere to be found, but based on the victim's injuries, it appeared
一位邻居碰巧看到凯伦的朋友在周六开车离开这栋房子，但在接下来的几个小时里，他们没有看到任何可疑情况。这家人在周日晚上成为了袭击目标。凯伦当时正睡在起居室的一个床垫上，遭到了袭击。接着，她的女儿们在卧室里遭遇了不测。目前尚不清楚丹尼尔的尸体是如何跑到外面的，不过一些人推测他可能是从房子里逃了出来，遭到袭击者的追赶，在车道上遭到致命打击。凶器不知去向，但根据受害者的伤势，似乎
their killer had been wielding either an axe, a tomahawk, or meat cleaver. Many foreign fingerprints were found throughout the home, but the challenge was ruling out who they belonged to. Seaman was also detected, but DNA technology was still in its infancy, and this couldn't be used to identify who was responsible. Grenaf's community were left shocked by the murders. Although Geraldton City and its surrounding region had its share of drug and theft-related offences, crimes of this magnitude were unheard of. Without a clear motive or suspect for the slayings, the township was gripped by fear that the
他们的凶手使用的是斧头、印第安战斧（tomahawk）或肉锤（meat cleaver）。屋里发现了许多不属于屋主的指纹，但面临的挑战是排除它们属于谁。还检测到了精液，但DNA技术仍处于起步阶段，无法利用它来确定谁是罪魁祸首。格里诺的社区对这些谋杀案感到震惊。尽管杰拉尔顿市及其周边地区也曾有过毒品和盗窃相关的犯罪，但如此规模的罪行闻所未闻。由于凶杀案没有明确的动机或嫌疑人，整个小镇陷入了一种恐惧之中，担心这个
unknown, sadistic killer would strike again. No one could understand why anyone would want to hurt Karen and her kids, especially in such a violent and deranged way. The police didn't say too much, as they didn't want to cause any unnecessary alarm. They simply warned the community to take proper safety measures. While it was possible that the killings were a random attack, this didn't appear to be the case. To get to the Mackenzie House, you had to exit the highway and travel a fair distance down a remote side street. There was nothing out there besides a few houses spread throughout the dry, rural flatlands. The only reason to be in the area was to visit one of these residences.
未知的、虐待狂般的杀手会再次作案。没有人能理解为什么会有人想要伤害凯伦和她的孩子，尤其是在如此暴力和疯狂的方式下。警方没有说太多，因为他们不想引起任何不必要的恐慌。他们只是警告社区采取适当的安全措施。虽然这些杀戮可能是随机袭击，但这似乎并非事实。要到达麦肯齐的房子，你必须离开高速公路，沿着偏僻的偏街行驶相当长的一段距离。那里除了散落在干燥平原上的几栋房子外，别无他物。来到该地区的唯一原因就是拜访其中一处住所。
It wasn't the kind of place an opportunistic killer would have stumbled across in their everyday travels. They had to be familiar not only with Granev, but its outskirts. It seemed they had set out on Georgina Road on that Sunday night, with every intention of attacking the Mackenzie family. Phone records from the Mackenzie property revealed that a call had been placed to the house at 11.15 the night of the killings. The caller was identified as a man who had previously lived at their property. He admitted to speaking to Karen at this time, but for innocent reasons. He claimed he went to bed straight after making the call.
这并不是那种机会主义杀手在日常出行中会偶然撞上的地方。他们不仅必须熟悉格里诺，还要熟悉它的郊区。似乎他们在那个星期日晚上出发驶上乔治娜路，怀揣着袭击麦肯齐一家的明确意图。麦肯齐住所的通话记录显示，在命案当晚11点15分，曾有人向这栋房子打过一个电话。打电话的人被确认是一名曾居住在他们房产里的男子。他承认当时与凯伦通了话，但理由是无辜的。他声称自己在打完电话后马上就睡觉了。
After police established a tip line, the pool of potential suspects grew quickly. There was Karen's former partner, Andrew Allen, who was the father to Amara and Katrina. He had contacted police after hearing about the murders on the news and was tracked down to Halls Creek, a small outback town over 2,000 kilometers northeast of Granev. Andrew maintained that he'd been stuck in Halls Creek during the time of the murders due to heavy rainfall that had flooded the roads leading in and out of town. Then there was Shane Eastoff, a man Karen had been seeing shortly before her murder. He told police that Karen had recently broken things off between them out of the blue.
在警方设立举报热线后，潜在嫌疑人的范围迅速扩大。其中有凯伦的前伴侣安德鲁·阿伦，他是阿马拉和卡特里娜的父亲。他在新闻上听到谋杀案后联系了警方，并被追踪到霍尔斯克里克（Halls Creek），这是格里诺东北方向2,000多公里处的一个偏远小镇。安德鲁坚称，由于大雨淹没了进出城镇的道路，他在谋杀案发生期间一直被困在霍尔斯克里克。然后是肖恩·东托夫（Shane Eastoff），一个凯伦在她遇害前不久一直在交往的男子。他告诉警方，凯伦最近无缘无故地和他们断绝了关系。
Then, a few days before the murders, Shane received an anonymous Valentine's Day card featuring Karen's handwriting. It read, What did I do? Care too much. To being your arms ain't so rough. Being yours could have been enough. What happened, babe? Scare you off. Like a diamond, you're just too tough. In the bottom left hand corner of the card, Karen had signed off with the word buy. In hindsight, Shane wondered whether this indicated that Karen knew something bad was about to happen. Then there was the sighting of two vehicles leaving the McKenzie property on the night of the murders. The witness hadn't seen either of the cars before and didn't know who they belonged to.
接着，在谋杀案发生几天前，肖恩收到了一张匿名的情人节卡片，上面有凯伦的笔迹。上面写着：“我做了什么？在乎得太多。躺在你的怀里并没有那么粗糙。成为你的人本该足够。发生什么了，宝贝？吓跑了你。就像一颗钻石，你只是太坚强了。”在卡片的左下角，凯伦签上了“买（buy）”这个词。事后回想起来，肖恩想知道这是否表明凯伦知道有什么不好的事情即将发生。然后，有人目击到在谋杀案当晚有两辆车离开麦肯齐的住所。目击者以前从未见过这两辆车中的任何一辆，也不知道它们属于谁。
This was just one of many unsubstantiated tips that served to further muddy the already perplexing investigation. There was also the suggestion that the crime could be drug related, as Karen was known to use recreationally and associate with other drug users and individuals linked to the cannabis trade. The city of Geraldton was a known sea passage that facilitated drug trafficking from Asia to Australia. Furthermore, the party Karen attended on the Friday night before her murder involved drug use. Those affiliated with the illicit scene typically kept a safe distance from police, but the murders had rocked the community so much that most people were willing to talk. Bikes and other gangs that were active in the area were
这只是众多未经证实的线索之一，这些线索进一步混淆了本已令人困惑的调查。还有人提出，这起犯罪可能与毒品有关，因为众所周知凯伦有吸毒习惯，并与其他吸毒者以及与大麻交易有关的人有交往。杰拉尔顿市是众所周知的 facilitates 亚洲至澳大利亚毒品走势的海上通道。此外，凯伦在她遇害前周五晚上参加的派对涉及吸毒。那些与非法圈子有染的人通常会与警察保持安全距离，但这些谋杀案对社区的震撼太大了，以至于大多数人愿意开口说话。该地区活跃的飞车党和其他帮派也
looked into, but the police couldn't find anything worthwhile to their investigations. However, they couldn't rule out that the crimes could be drug related in some way. Then, a witness came forward having seen Karen in Geraldton on the Sunday morning before the attack. She had been speaking to a fisherman who was working in the area at the time. Police looked into the fisherman and discovered that he had left to Geraldton for the city of Darwin in the neighbouring state of the Northern Territory the day the bodies were found. They tracked him down, only to find that he had no alibi for the night of the murders. By now, 70 persons of interest had emerged throughout the Grannath and Geraldton regions
受到了调查，但警方没有找到对他们的调查有价值的东西。然而，他们不能排除这些罪行在某种程度上与毒品有关的可能性。随后，一名目击者站出来，称在袭击发生前的周日早上在杰拉尔顿看到了凯伦。她当时正在与一名当时在当地工作的渔民交谈。警方调查了这名渔民，发现他在发现尸体的当天就离开了杰拉尔顿，前往邻近的北领地（Northern Territory）城市达尔文（Darwin）。他们找到了他，却发现他在谋杀案当晚没有不在场证明。到目前为止，在格里诺和杰拉尔顿地区以及跨州范围内，已经出现了70名嫌疑人。
and interstate. Police continued to speculate possible motives, but they were plagued by uncertainty. The sheer brutality of the attack using a handheld bludgeon indicated that the perpetrator was compelled by something personal, such as revenge. Yet, the necrophilia and child sexual assault indicated something else entirely. While a motive and suspect eluded them, police didn't cover one major clue. While carrying out the crimes, the Mackenzie family killer pressed his right hand against an interior wall. His palm was smeared with an oily substance, which left a partial palm print. In the same room, there were three oily fingertip prints on the edge of a door. These markings appeared to have been made as the killer closed the door
警方继续推测可能的动机，但他们饱受不确定性的困扰。使用手持钝器的袭击纯粹的残暴性表明，行凶者受到诸如复仇之类极其私人的事情驱使。然而，恋尸癖和儿童性侵则完全指向了其他东西。尽管动机和嫌疑人仍然难以捉摸，但警方并没有漏掉一个重大线索。在实施犯罪时，麦肯齐一家的凶手将他的右手按在一面内墙上。他的手掌上沾满了油性物质，留下了一个部分手掌印。在同一个房间里，门边有三个油性的指尖印。这些印记似乎是凶手关上身后的门时留下的。
behind them. The section of wall containing the palm print was cut out and taken away for examination. The fingerprints were less viable as the door had originally been painted with a coarse paintbrush using rough strokes. Still, investigators removed the entire door so it too could undergo forensic testing. At the Western Australia Chem Centre in Perth, a chief research chemist and his team got to work testing the oily prints. Given that they weren't full fingerprints, their best bet was to identify what the oily substance was. The team concluded the print had been made using a sorboline like substance, which is a common type of hand lotion. But they couldn't be sure exactly what the product was. The chem centre kept a catalogue of approximately 80 different hand and body lotions
包含掌印的那段墙壁被切割下来拿走进行检查。指纹的可用性较差，因为这扇门最初是用粗毛刷以粗糙的笔触涂过漆的。不过，调查人员拆下了整扇门，以便它也能接受法医测试。在珀斯的西澳化学中心（Western Australia Chem Centre），首席研究化学家和他的团队开始着手检测这些油性质地。鉴于它们不是完整的指纹，他们最好的办法是确定油性物质是什么。该团队得出结论，这些印记是用类似于索博林（sorboline）的物质制成的，这是一种常见的护手霜。但他们无法确定具体是什么产品。化学中心现场保存了大约80种不同的手部和身体乳液目录。
on site. The substance was tested against each one, but no match was found. The team then gathered all the various lotions present in the McKenzie household and tested the substance against those. But they couldn't find a match there either. The last time Geraldton resident Hamish Langford, not his real name, saw Karen McKenzie, was at the house party he'd hosted three days before she was killed. As the murder investigation gained pace, Hamish returned home to find a ghastly scene. His house had been broken into and there was a significant amount of blood on the floor. Panicked, Hamish phoned the police who quickly arrived at the scene.
该物质针对每一种进行了测试，但没有找到匹配项。然后，该团队收集了麦肯齐家中现有的各种乳液，并将该物质与这些乳液进行了对比测试。但他们在那里面也没有找到匹配项。杰拉尔顿居民哈米什·兰格福德（Hamish Langford，化名）最后一次见到凯伦·麦肯齐，是在她被杀前三天他主办的家庭派对上。随着谋杀案调查的加速，哈米什回家后发现了一个可怕的场景。他的房子遭到了入室盗窃，地板上有大量的血迹。惊慌失措的哈米什打电话给警察，警察很快赶到了现场。
The amount of blood indicated someone had been seriously injured and police feared the McKenzie family murderer had struck again. As they considered this, the back door of Hamish's home flung open. Standing in the doorway was a naked man with a blood-soaked towel wrapped around his waist. He was frantic, telling police that he'd arrived at the address earlier to visit Hamish. When he knocked on the door, three men appeared out of nowhere and dragged him inside. The trio were convinced that Hamish was responsible for the McKenzie murders and demanded to know where he was so they could confront him. The man insisted that he didn't know, but his assailants didn't believe him. Suddenly, one took out a filleting knife
血迹的数量表明有人受了重伤，警方担心麦肯齐一家的凶手再次作案了。正当他们这样想着时，哈米什家后门猛地被推开了。站在门槛上的是一个赤身裸体的男子，腰间缠着一条血迹斑斑的毛巾。他情绪狂乱，告诉警察他早些时候来到这个地址拜访哈米什。当他敲门时，三个不知从哪里冒出来的男人把他拖了进去。这三人坚信哈米什应对麦肯齐的谋杀案负责，并要求知道他在哪里以便与他当面对质。该男子坚称他不知道，但他的袭击者不相信他。突然，其中一人掏出一把剔骨刀
and attempted to sever the man's penis. The man fought for his life and broke free. He raced into a bathroom before locking the door behind him. The offending trio finally left, but fearing they'd come back, the injured man darted outside and hid in some bushes. He waited there until he saw the police arrive. The man was rushed to Geraldton Regional Hospital and treated for his injuries. While police wanted to give him time to recover, they were also eager to get as much information about his three attackers while his memory was fresh. They pressed him for any details, asking for a description of the trio.
并试图割断该男子的阴茎。该男子为生命而战并挣脱了。他冲进一间浴室，在身后锁上了门。行凶的三人组终于离开了，但由于担心他们会回来，受伤的男子冲到外面躲进了一些灌木丛中。他在那里等待，直到看到警察到达。该男子被紧急送往杰拉尔顿地区医院并接受了伤情治疗。虽然警方想给他时间恢复，但他们也急于在记忆犹新时获取有关他三个袭击者的尽可能多的信息。他们向他施压，索取任何细节，要求提供三人组的体貌特征。
The man was hesitant, but the pressure soon got to him. He admitted he had made the whole story up. Struggling with the drug addiction and personal issues, he'd inflicted the knife wounds in a suicide attempt gone awry. This was not the first time police had spoken to this individual. His name was Bill Mitchell, and he was one of the 70 persons of interest that had emerged in the investigation, having been one of the last people to see Karen alive. Hamish Langford's house party was in full swing on the night of Friday, February 19th.
这名男子有些犹豫，但压力很快压垮了他。他承认整个故事都是他自己编造的。由于饱受毒品成瘾和个人问题的困扰，他在一次弄巧成拙的自杀未遂中给自己造成了刀伤。这并不是警方第一次与此人交谈。他的名字叫比尔·M切尔（Bill Mitchell），他是调查中浮出水面的70名嫌疑人之一，也是最后一批见到凯伦活著的人之一。2月19日星期五晚上，哈米什·兰格福德的家庭派对正如火如荼地进行着。
His guests were mingling, alcohol was flowing, and some were partaking in recreational drug use. For the most part, it was an enjoyable evening. That was until a drunken argument broke out between Karen McKenzie and her friend Bill Mitchell. The other guests weren't sure what the fight was about exactly, but it brought down the atmosphere, and some left as a result. Although no one knew what Bill had done to upset Karen, their issues seemed to have dissipated by the early hours, as Karen had accepted Bill's offer of a ride home.
他的客人们在社交，美酒流转，有些人还在进行娱乐性吸毒。大部分时间里，这是一个令人愉快的夜晚。直到凯伦·麦肯齐和她的朋友比尔·米切尔之间爆发了一场酒后争吵。其他客人们并不确定这场争吵究竟是为了什么，但它破坏了气氛，一些人因此离开了。尽管没有人知道比尔做了什么惹恼了凯伦，但在清晨时分，他们的问题似乎已经消散，因为凯伦接受了比尔提供的一程车回家的好意。
They arrived at her house around 5am on Saturday morning. Bill hung out there until 11am, before driving back to Geraldton. This was verified by a neighbour who saw Bill's car leaving the McKenzie property at this time. When initially questioned by police, Bill maintained he had nothing to do with the murders that occurred the following night. He showed great concern for Karen and her children. Therefore, when Bill Mitchell staged an attack on himself at the house where he and Karen had fought in the days before her murder, police were baffled.
他们在周六清晨5点左右到达了她的房子。比尔在那里逗留到上午11点，然后开车返回杰拉尔顿。这得到了邻居的证实，邻居看到比尔的车在这个时候离开了麦肯齐的住所。在最初接受警方讯问时，比尔坚称他与第二天晚上发生的谋杀案毫无关系。他表现出对凯伦和她的孩子的极大关切。因此，当比尔·米切尔在凯伦遇害前几天与她争吵过的房子里对自己策划了一场袭击时，警方感到大惑不解。
He was charged with making a false statement in relation to the knife attack, and left to recover from his injuries. Greenhead Caravan Park is around a 2-hour drive south of Greeniff. The most direct route is along the Brand Highway, which connects to the scenic Indian Ocean Drive. Here, the road offers endless views of Western Australia's coast on one side, and its jagged, tan-coloured countryside on the other. A turn leads down to the coastal town of Greenhead,
他被指控就刀伤事件作虚假陈述，并被留下来休养伤势。格林黑德大篷车公园（Greenhead Caravan Park）距离格里诺向南约有2小时车程。最直接的路线是沿着布兰德高速公路行驶，该公路连接风景秀丽的印度洋大道（Indian Ocean Drive）。在这里，道路一边是西澳海岸的无尽美景，另一边是其参差不齐、呈黄褐色的乡村风光。一个路口通向沿海小镇格林黑德，
a tourist hotspot for those seeking sun, sand, and surf. Many opt to stay at the Greenhead Caravan Park, as it's just a short walk from the beach. In the early 90s, the park was run by a man named Bernie MacArthur. Although it was some distance from where the Mackenzie family was murdered, Bernie was immediately reminded of the case when one of his employees came to him in a shaken state. They had entered one of the on-site caravans to do a routine clean, when they were greeted by a man who had been shot in the face.
这是寻求阳光、沙滩和冲浪者的旅游热点。许多人选择住在格林黑德大篷车公园，因为它距离海滩只有几步之遥。在90年代初，这个公园由一个名叫伯尼·麦克阿瑟（Bernie MacArthur）的男子管理。尽管这里距离麦肯齐一家被谋杀的地方有一段距离，但当他的一名员工惊恐万状地来找他时，伯尼立刻想到了这起案件。他们进入其中一间现场大篷车进行例行清洁时，迎面看到一个面部中枪的男子。
Large amounts of blood and semen were splattered throughout, along with a ripped-up pornographic magazine. Although there was nothing to indicate this incident had anything to do with the Mackenzie murders, Bernie couldn't shake his suspicion of a possible connection. Like other locals along the coastline, he'd been rattled by the crimes and was anxious for the perpetrator to be caught. He called the local police, who came to assess the caravan and bagged the evidence. When the task force fronting the Mackenzie family investigation was notified of the
大量血迹和精液四处飞溅，还有一本被撕碎的色情杂志。尽管没有任何迹象表明这起事件与麦肯齐谋杀案有任何关系，但伯尼无法摆脱可能存在联系的怀疑。就像沿海地区的其他当地人一样，他被这些罪行震惊了，渴望抓到凶手。他打电话给当地警察，警察前来评估了大篷车并打包了证据。当领导麦肯齐一家谋杀案调查的专案组接到这一
disturbing discovery, they decided to withhold all details of it from the media. By now, they had narrowed their list down to 25 persons of interest. Each individual was tracked down and asked to provide hair, blood and saliva samples. Forensic Inspector Bryn Jones had been one of the first officers at the Mackenzie family crime scene, and was working hard to keep his word about finding the person responsible. His tireless endeavours led him to the small agricultural town of Morawa, 149km east of Greeniff. There, he met a familiar face, Bill Mitchell. Bill had since recovered from his suicide attempt and had resumed his job as a farm hand.
令人不安的发现时，他们决定向媒体隐瞒所有细节。此时，他们已将嫌疑人名单缩小到25人。每个人都被追踪到并被要求提供头发、血液和唾液样本。法医督察布林·琼斯是麦肯齐一家犯罪现场的第一批警官之一，他一直在努力兑现关于找到责任人的诺言。他坚持不懈的努力将他带到了莫拉瓦（Morawa）这个小型农业城镇，该镇位于格里诺以东149公里处。在那里，他遇到了一个熟悉的面孔，比尔·米切尔。比尔此后从自杀未遂中恢复过来，并恢复了他作为农场工人的工作。
When asked to volunteer to have his fingerprints taken, Bill agreed. Inspector Jones set up his inking equipment. As he began taking the prints, Bill remarked, I'm surprised you're still going on with the investigation. I thought you caught the bloke. I heard in the press that he was behaving really strangely in some caravan park and you caught up with him. Jones froze. The caravan incident at Greenhead Caravan Park had been withheld from the public. No one outside of the task force knew about it. Jones kept his cool. He calmly finished taking Bill's prints and left the farm, before rushing them to Perth for testing. At the chem centre in Perth, chief research chemist Dr John Chalanoir and his team were
当被要求自愿采集指纹时，比尔同意了。琼斯督察摆好了采墨设备。当他开始采集指纹时，比尔评论道：“我很惊讶你还在继续调查。我以为你已经抓到那家伙了。我在报纸上听说他在某个大篷车公园里表现得真的很奇怪，然后你们抓住了他。”琼斯僵住了。格林黑德大篷车公园的大篷车事件一直对公众保密。专案组以外的任何人都不知道这件事。琼斯保持冷静。他平静地完成了比尔的指纹采集并离开了农场，随后匆忙将它们送到珀斯进行检测。在珀斯的化学中心，首席研究化学家约翰·查拉努瓦博士（Dr John Chalanoir）和他的团队
still working to identify the mysterious lotion left behind at the Mackenzie crime scene. Having worked on many sexual assault cases during his career, he was able to identify the mysterious lotion left behind at the Mackenzie crime scene. Dr Chalanoir was aware that perpetrators sometimes used hand lotion as a lubricant. Wondering if that could explain the oily palm and fingerprints, he requested that the mysterious lotion be compared against swabs taken from Karen Mackenzie's body. If there was a match, it would prove that the oily fingerprints belonged to the perpetrator. The same substance was present on Karen's body, confirming that the oily hand and
仍在努力鉴定遗留在麦肯齐犯罪现场的神秘润滑乳液。由于在他的职业生涯中处理过许多性侵案件，他能够识别出遗留在麦肯齐犯罪现场的神秘乳液。查拉努瓦博士意识到行凶者有时会使用护手霜作为润滑剂。想知道这是否能解释油性掌印和指纹，他要求将神秘乳液与从凯伦·麦肯齐尸体上提取的棉签进行比对。如果有匹配项，将证明油性指纹属于行凶者。凯伦的尸体上也存在同样的物质，这证实了犯罪现场的油性手印和
fingerprints at the crime scene absolutely belonged to her killer. Bill Mitchell's prints were compared to those found at the murder scene. When Inspector Jones received the results, he raced into the office of his colleague, Detective Murf Cousins, who had also been working the case since its inception. Cousins triumphantly slapped his hand down on the desk and said, For the next two days, Bill Mitchell was kept under close surveillance. He continued to go about his daily life as though he had nothing to hide. At one point, he was chatting with his boss while the two worked in the farm's shearing shed,
指纹绝对属于她的杀手。比尔·米切尔的指纹与在谋杀现场发现的指纹进行了比对。当琼斯督察收到结果时，他冲进了同事默夫·库赞侦探的办公室，后者也从案件一开始就参与了侦探工作。库赞得意洋洋地把手重重拍在桌子上说：“……”在接下来的两天里，比尔·米切尔受到严密监视。他继续过着他的日常生活，就好像他没有什么好隐瞒的一样。有一次，他和老板在农场的剪毛棚里工作时聊天，
and he even raised the subject of the murders. Then, on Saturday, March 27, senior detectives travelled up from Perth and took Bill Mitchell in for questioning. They told him that his fingerprints had been linked to the hand lotion used in the rape of Karen Mackenzie's corpse and that they knew he was responsible for the murders. When faced with this evidence, Mitchell didn't deny it. Instead, he spoke coldly and candidly. His statement took detectives back to just over a month earlier in late February when he attended Hamish Langford's house party in Geraldton. Following the spat he had there with Karen, Mitchell convinced Karen to let him drive her home.
甚至还主动提起了谋杀案。接着，在3月27日星期六，高级侦探从珀斯赶来，将比尔·米切尔带去审讯。他们告诉他，他的指纹与强奸凯伦·麦肯齐尸体时使用的护手霜有关，他们知道他是凶手。面对这些证据，米切尔没有否认。相反，他冷酷而坦率地开口了。他的供词把侦探们带回了一个多月前的2月下旬，当时他参加了哈米什·兰格福德在杰拉尔顿举办的家庭派对。在与凯伦在那里发生争吵后，米切尔说服凯伦让她开车送她回家。
Upon arriving at her place, Mitchell tried to have sex with Karen, but she turned him down. Mitchell was infuriated by the rejection. He left the house and spent the following day of Sunday, February 21 in an anger-fuelled bender, consuming alcohol, prescription painkillers, cannabis, and amphetamines. By 2.30 am, he was in an intoxicated haze. It was then that he made the decision Karen and her family had to die. He got in his car and made the 25-kilometer drive to Greenough. 16-year-old Daniel was awake inside his home when he caught sight of a pair of headlights travelling up the driveway. The unexpected arrival prompted him to head out into the early morning
到达她家后，米切尔试图与凯伦发生性关系，但她拒绝了他。米切尔对被拒绝感到愤怒。他离开了房子，并在接下来的2月21日星期日度过了一段充满愤怒的纵欲时光，酗酒、服用处方止痛药、大麻和安非他命。到凌晨2点30分，他处于一种因过度饮酒而意识模糊的状态。正是在那时，他做出了凯伦和她的家人必须死的决定。他上了车，开车25公里来到格里诺。16岁的丹尼尔在家里醒着，突然看到一束车灯顺着车道驶来。这突如其来的到来促使他走到清晨的
darkness to investigate. As Daniel approached, Mitchell emerged from his car with an axe and unleashed his fury on the unsuspecting teen. This explained how Daniel's body came to be outside. Once he had killed Daniel, Mitchell headed into the house where Karen McKenzie was asleep in the lounge room. He turned the axe on her, striking her multiple times like he had done to her son. He then went into her bedroom and rifled through her drawers until he found a bottle of hand lotion, which he used as lubricant to sexually assault her body. Afterwards, he headed into the children's bedroom, where he viciously assaulted and murdered 7-year-old Amara. He then killed 5-year-old Katrina while she slept.
黑暗中去查看。当丹尼尔走近时，米切尔拿着一把斧头从车里钻出来，将他的怒火宣泄在这个毫无防备的少年身上。这解释了丹尼尔的尸体是如何跑到外面的。一旦杀死了丹尼尔，米切尔就走进屋内，凯伦·麦肯齐正睡在起居室里。他把斧头转向她，像对她儿子那样对她进行了多次打击。然后他走进她的卧室，翻箱倒柜，直到找到了一瓶护手霜，他用它作为润滑剂对她的尸体进行了性侵。之后，他走进孩子们的卧室，残忍地袭击并谋杀了7岁的阿马拉。随后，趁5岁的卡特里娜熟睡时杀害了她。
Mitchell then went into the bathroom and cleaned himself up. Determined not to leave any evidence behind, he took the axe and the hand lotion with him when he drove away from the property. As he made his way back to Geraldton, he pulled over and threw the axe in the Greenough River. He disposed of the hand lotion in a rubbish bin. This explained why the forensic team couldn't link the greasy substance to any of the products found inside the McKenzie home. Mitchell took investigators through each step of his actions in clinical, callous detail. Although he admitted going to the property with the intention of killing the entire McKenzie family, he claimed he couldn't remember what motivated him to do so.
随后，米切尔走进浴室清洗干净。为了不留下任何证据，他在开车离开时带走了斧头和护手霜。在返回杰拉尔顿的途中，他将车停下，把斧头扔进了格林诺河。他将护手霜扔进了一个垃圾桶里。这就解释了为什么法医团队无法将这种油腻物质与麦肯齐家中的任何产品联系起来。米切尔以冷静、冷酷的细节向调查人员讲述了他每一个动作的过程。虽然他承认去那里的目的是杀死整个麦肯齐家族，但他声称自己记不清是什么动机促使他这么做的。
The detectives couldn't believe what they were hearing. Nothing could prepare them for Mitchell's detailed play-by-play of how he single-handedly cut down an entire family, including two young children. Even as he described the worst elements of the attack, Mitchell remained stoic and unaffected. To forensic inspector Bryn Jones, Bill Mitchell was so void of emotion that he might as well have been describing how he washed his car. Following Mitchell's confession, a team of police divers entered the murky shallows of the Greenough River. While the expansive waterway ran 340km into the Indian Ocean, they knew exactly where to look. If nothing else, Bill Mitchell was accurate.
侦探们简直不敢相信他们所听到的。没有什么能让他们对米切尔详细描述他是如何一手残害一整家人（包括两个小孩子）的行径做好心理准备。即使在描述袭击中最惨烈的部分时，米切尔依然无动于衷、神情冷漠。在法医检查员布林·琼斯看来，比尔·米切尔表现得如此毫无感情，就好像他是在描述自己是如何洗车的一样。在米切尔供认之后，一队警方潜水员进入了格林诺河混浊的浅水区。虽然这条广阔的水道绵延340公里注入印度洋，但他们确切地知道该去哪里找。如果说别的方面不谈，比尔·米切尔的记忆倒还算准确。
A diver recovered the murder weapon to the applause of those watching on, but the jubilation was momentary. Once they saw the axe, the full weight of what they'd uncovered hit home. Despite being submerged in the river for five weeks, the axe was still stained with blood and covered with bits of hair. On March 30, 1993, William Bill Mitchell appeared at the Geraldton Court and was formally charged with four counts of willful murder, three counts of indecently interfering with the corpse, and one count of sexual penetration of a child. He also faced charges for three unrelated thefts that occurred in November of 1991,
在围观群众的掌声中，一名潜水员打捞出了凶器，但这种喜悦只是短暂的。一旦看到这把斧头，他们所揭露真相的沉重打击便涌上心头。尽管在河里浸泡了五个星期，斧头上依然沾满血迹，并覆着丝丝头发。1993年3月30日，威廉·比尔·米切尔在杰拉尔顿法院出庭，正式被控四项蓄意谋杀罪、三项猥亵尸体罪以及一项对儿童实施性渗透罪。他还面临三项与1991年11月发生的盗窃案无关的指控，
including armed robbery with threats of violence. An angry mob gathered outside the courthouse, and as Mitchell was driven away, they booed and hissed at the police van. At the Perth Supreme Court on September 8, 1993, Mitchell pleaded guilty to all charges, but blamed his actions on his drug and alcohol abuse. His lawyer argued that Mitchell was in a drug-induced frenzy when he decided to kill Karen, Daniel, Amara, and Katrina, and that the crimes were completely without motive or premeditation. But the judge wasn't buying it. He pointed out that Mitchell had admitted going to the Mackenzie House with the intent to kill the family, and therefore, the murders were
其中包括伴随暴力威胁的持械抢劫。一群愤怒的民众聚集在法院外，当米切尔被车带走时，他们向警车发出嘘声和倒彩。1993年9月8日，在珀斯最高法院，米切尔对所有指控表示认罪，但将自己的行为归咎于毒品和酒精滥用。他的律师辩称，米切尔在决定杀死凯伦、丹尼尔、阿马拉和卡特里娜时处于吸毒狂乱状态，这些犯罪完全没有动机或预谋。但法官并不买账。他指出，米切尔已经承认前往麦肯齐家时怀有杀害一家的意图，因此，这些谋杀是
entirely premeditated. While the judge was prepared to accept that Mitchell might not have committed the crimes had he not been under the influence of drugs, that didn't warrant leniency. The fact that he'd managed to make the 25-kilometre drive from Geraldton to Greenough and back again, while disposing of the evidence, was proof that he was still able to function with precision. The acute recall he had of his crime spree confirmed that he knew exactly what he was doing. Although Mitchell stood by his claim that he didn't know why he decided to carry out the murders, the judge believed he was motivated by rejection. The fact that Karen had turned down his sexual advances angered him so much that he stewed over it all weekend before deciding
完全有预谋的。虽然法官愿意接受这样的假设：如果不是受到毒品影响，米切尔可能不会犯罪，但这并不构成宽大处理的理由。他设法从杰拉尔顿驱车25公里往返于格林诺之间，同时处理掉证据，这证明他在行动时仍然能够保持精确的机能。他对犯罪狂潮的清晰记忆证实了他非常清楚自己在做什么。尽管米切尔坚称自己不知道为什么要实施这些谋杀，但法官认为他是出于遭到拒绝而产生动机。凯伦拒绝了他的性接触，这让他极其愤怒，以至于他整个周末都在琢磨此事，最后决定
Karen and her children must die. Bill Mitchell was sentenced to life imprisonment. In his sentencing remarks, the judge described the murders as so serious that they almost defied description and were accompanied by sexual activity of the most depraved kind. The crimes against the children were so horrific that the full details of what they had endured were permanently sealed, never to be released to the public. In the Australian legal system, a person who's sentenced to life in prison is still given the right to apply for parole, unless they are considered to be so irredeemable that there's no prospect of rehabilitation. Due to Bill Mitchell's drug addiction, his sentencing judge said,
凯伦和她的孩子们必须死。比尔·米切尔被判处终身监禁。在量刑陈词中，法官将这些谋杀描述为极其严重、几乎难以用言语形容，并伴随着极其堕落的性行为。对孩子们的犯罪如此骇人听闻，以至于他们所遭受折磨的全部细节被永久封存，永不对公众公开。在澳大利亚法律体系中，被判处终身监禁的人仍然享有申请假释的权利，除非他们被认为无可救药、没有改过自新的可能。由于比尔·米切尔的毒瘾，量刑法官说：
I am not able to say that you will always be a danger to the public. That depends on whether you will stay away from drugs. Who knows what the future holds. I cannot prognosticate 20 years or more into the future. Therefore, he ruled that Mitchell would be eligible for parole in 20 years time. However, he explained, So far as I am concerned, you will never be released. If the parole board looks at it in the same way as I do, it could be many, many years greater than 20 before you would merit consideration. Mitchell remained emotionless and unremorseful throughout his sentencing. At the time, he was only 24 years old. If his parole was successful, he would only be 44 when released. Not only did that leave years of freedom ahead of him,
我无法断言你将永远对公众构成危险。这取决于你是否能远离毒品。谁知道未来会发生什么。我无法预测20年甚至更久以后的未来。因此，他裁定米切尔将在20年内有资格获得假释。然而他解释说，就我而言，你永远不会被释放。如果假释委员会的看法与我相同，那么在你值得被考虑之前，可能会远远超过20年。米切尔在整个宣判过程中表现得冷漠且毫无悔意。当时，他年仅24岁。如果假释成功，他获释时也才44岁。这不仅意味着他未来有数年的自由，
but it also meant that he'd ultimately only serve five years for each of the murders and nothing for the sexual assaults. Karen's family were outraged, as were the rest of the public. They thought Mitchell should lose the right to parole and the government agreed. The ruling was appealed to the Western Australian Supreme Court and in a two-to-one vote, the bench agreed that Bill Mitchell should spend the rest of his natural life in prison. Mitchell's legal team appealed the decision to the High Court. They acknowledged the magnitude of his crimes, but argued that he wasn't a serial killer or repeat offender. Instead, they once again blamed his actions on his drug addiction and argued that once he'd overcome
这也意味着他最终为每起谋杀只服刑五年，而对性侵则无需承担刑期。凯伦的家人感到愤怒，公众也是如此。他们认为米切尔应该失去假释权，政府也表示赞同。这项裁决被上诉至西澳大利亚最高法院，经过二比一的投票，合议庭一致认为比尔·米切尔应该在监狱里度过其余的自然寿命。米切尔的法律团队将该决定上诉至高等法院。他们承认他罪行严重，但辩称他不是连环杀手或累犯。相反，他们再次将他的行为归咎于毒瘾，并辩称一旦他戒除
the addiction, he would no longer pose a threat. The High Court agreed. Once again, Bill Mitchell was granted the right to apply for parole after serving just 20 years. The Australian community were appalled and cried for the return of the death penalty, which had been abolished across the country by 1985. Karen's sister, Evelyn, responded to the uproar. Quite frankly, the death penalty would be too quick for him. If you hang someone, they don't suffer. If they get a needle, they don't suffer. I want him to suffer for the rest of his life. I want him to think about what he did.
毒瘾，他将不再构成威胁。高等法院表示赞同。比尔·米切尔再次获得了在服刑仅20年后申请假释的权利。澳大利亚社会对此感到震惊，并呼吁恢复死刑，该刑罚已于1985年在全国范围内被废除。凯伦的妹妹伊芙琳对这场轩然大波作出回应。坦白说，死刑对他来说太快了。如果你绞死某人，他们不会痛苦。如果你注射，他们不会痛苦。我希望他在余生中受折磨。我希望他去回想自己所做的事。
Ever since the murder of her sister, nephew and nieces, Evelyn lived in a constant state of flight or fight, knowing that Bill Mitchell could one day be free. Even when going about simple daily tasks, she was always on high alert. She wasn't the only one suffering. Many friends and family of the McKenzie family faced some level of profound and permanent grief over the killings. Some endured post-traumatic stress disorder and required ongoing therapy and psychiatric care. They couldn't understand why some perpetrators who killed just one person received large sentences when Bill Mitchell had killed an entire family and only received 20. In 2007, Karen's mother, Barbara, said,
自从她的姐姐、外甥和外甥女被谋杀以来，伊芙琳一直生活在持续的战斗或逃跑状态中，因为她知道比尔·米切尔有朝一日可能会重获自由。甚至在处理简单的日常琐事时，她也总是处于高度戒备状态。她并不是唯一一个遭受痛苦的人。麦肯齐的许多亲友因这些谋杀案而面临不同程度的深刻且永久的悲伤。有些人患上了创伤后应激障碍，并需要长期的治疗和精神护理。他们无法理解，为什么有些杀害一个人的凶犯会受到重判，而比尔·米切尔残害了一整家人却只判了20年。2007年，凯伦的母亲芭芭拉说：
14 years on and I'm still angry. My life is spent always wondering if he'll be released. For all we know, he could walk out and could kill someone else, and I would hate for somebody to have to go through what we went through. Where's the sense in our laws? The things Mitchell did were beyond belief. I feel so much hatred. Why kill two helpless little girls and do what he did to her and to do the same thing to my daughter? She was dead for Christ's sakes. Why would you want to rape a dead body? The man has to be sick. He has to stay in jail. God forbid if he comes out when he is 44. He's got plenty of time to do it to somebody else, hasn't he? It frightens me. One year later, an unexpected letter arrived at Barbara's house in Queensland. It read,
14年过去了，我依然很愤怒。我的生活总是在琢磨他是否会被释放。据我们所知，他可能会大摇大摆走出来并杀害其他人，我可不希望任何人经历我们所经历过的一切。我们的法律道理何在？米切尔所做的事简直匪夷所思。我感到无比痛恨。为什么要杀死两个无助的小女孩，对她做出那种事，又对我的女儿做出同样的事？看在上帝的份上，她已经死了。你为什么会想去强奸一具尸体？这人肯定有病。他必须待在监狱里。天哪，如果他在44岁出来，那就糟了。他有的是时间对别人下手，不是吗？这让我感到害怕。一年后，一封意想不到的信件寄到了芭芭拉在昆士兰的家中。信上写着：
Bound you bitch, had someone look for you, got a photo of your little girl, short hair, white shirt and a little skirt. Nice. See you when I get out. It was signed from William. Barbara was terrified. The description fit that of her 11 year old granddaughter. Fearing that Bill Mitchell was plotting another attack against her family, Barbara reported the letter to the police. They checked Mitchell's prison records and confirmed that he was banned from sending any correspondence to Barbara. Furthermore, he hadn't sent anything to anyone in Queensland. The letter had been sent shortly after the Foxtel television series Crime Investigation Australia aired an episode about the Mackenzie case. Police believed the letter was nothing
绑了你这贱人，让人找过你了，拍了你小女孩的照片，短发、白衬衣和小裙子。真不错。等我出去见你。信的署名是威廉。芭芭拉吓坏了。这个描述符合她11岁孙女的特征。由于担心比尔·米切尔在策划针对她家人的另一次袭击，芭芭拉向警方报了案。他们检查了米切尔的监狱记录，证实他被禁止向芭芭拉发送任何信件。此外，他也没有向昆士兰的任何人寄过东西。这封信是在福克斯电视台系列节目《澳大利亚犯罪调查》播出一集关于麦肯齐案的节目后不久寄出的。警方认为这封信只不过是
more than a cruel hoax orchestrated by someone who had watched the show. In 2010, another blow came to the family when Mitchell was moved from a maximum security to a medium security prison. Karen's sister, Evelyn, then made the brave decision to face the man who single-handedly wiped out four members of her family. She didn't care to ask why he committed the crimes. She simply wanted him to know how much pain he'd caused. Evelyn was accompanied by two mediators armed with panic buttons in case anything went wrong, while two guards kept watch close by. Bill Mitchell nervously entered the small room with his eyes lowered. He sat just a few feet away from Evelyn, close enough that she could hear
看过节目的某人精心策划的一个残酷恶作剧。2010年，当米切尔从最高安全级别监狱转到中等安全级别监狱时，这个家庭再次遭受打击。凯伦的妹妹伊芙琳随后做出勇敢的决定，去面对那个一手毁灭她家中四口人的凶手。她不关心去问他为什么要犯罪。她只是想让他知道他带来了多少痛苦。伊芙琳由两名配备紧急按钮的调解员陪同，以防万一出现问题，同时两名警卫在附近密切注视。比尔·米切尔低着头，神情紧张地走进小房间。他坐在离伊芙琳只有几英尺远的地方，近得她能听见
him breathing heavily. She was taken aback by how normal he looked. Evelyn sat across from Mitchell and thanked him for meeting her. Mitchell then apologized, saying he was a changed man and a model prisoner. This meant nothing to Evelyn. She told him it was easy to behave when he was surrounded by people who could kill him if he stepped out of line. She then asked if he ever wanted to get out of jail. Mitchell said yes, that the possibility was giving him some kind of light at the end of the tunnel. Evelyn then told him she would use every breath in her body to make sure that never happened, saying, I want you to know I will do everything I can to keep you in jail.
他沉重的呼吸声。他的外表看起来如此正常，这让她感到吃惊。伊芙琳坐在米切尔对面，感谢他前来见她。米切尔随后道歉，称自己是一个脱胎换骨的人，也是一名模范囚犯。这在伊芙琳看来毫无意义。她告诉他，当周围都是那些在他敢出格时就能杀了它的人时，装乖是很轻而易举的。接着她问他是否曾想过离开监狱。米切尔说是的，这种可能性给了他隧道尽头的一些曙光。伊芙琳随后告诉他，她会用她体内的每一口气来确保这种情况永远不会发生，并说道：“我想让你知道，我会竭尽所能把你关在监狱里。”
The moment of truth came in 2013, when Mitchell was able to apply for parole for the first time. The Mackenzie's loved ones were on edge, but were relieved when his request was denied, based on the severity of his crimes and the possible threat he posed to community safety. However, now that he'd served 20 years, Western Australia law dictated that Mitchell's case would automatically be up for review every three years. This was unsettling news for those closest to the victims. Evelyn said, This is just really hard to deal with, knowing that it's never going to end. As long as he's alive, it will never end. It's just something that we have to do every couple of years. In 2016, as Bill Mitchell's second parole hearing approached, Evelyn started a petition
真相大白的时刻出现在2013年，当时米切尔首次得以申请假释。麦肯齐的亲人们如坐针毡，但当他的请求因其罪行的严重性以及对社区安全构成的潜在威胁而被拒绝时，他们松了一口气。然而，既然他已经服刑20年，西澳大利亚法律规定米切尔的案子将每三年自动接受一次复审。这对受害者的至亲来说是个令人不安的消息。伊芙琳说：“这真的很难面对，因为你知道这一切永远不会结束。只要他还活着，就永远不会结束。这只是我们每隔几年就必须做的事情。”2016年，随着比尔·米切尔的第二次假释听证会临近，伊芙琳发起了一场请愿
to have the laws changed so that he could never be released from prison. Over two and a half thousand people signed the petition, but Attorney General Michael Mission said there would be no changes to the current parole review process. He explained it was necessary to ensure that no prisoner got lost in the system. Evelyn said, Mitchell deserves nothing for what he did, and I will say that to him a thousand times. He deserves nothing because he took so much away from so many precious people. Each year on the anniversary of the murders, Evelyn takes a day off to remember Karen, Daniel, Amara and Katrina. While she can never forgive Bill Mitchell for what he did, she refuses to let it make her a
要求修改法律，以便他永远无法从监狱获释。两千五百多人在请愿书上签名，但总检察长迈克尔·米申表示，当前的假释复审程序不会有任何改变。他解释说，这是为了确保没有任何囚犯在系统中迷失方向。伊芙琳说：“对于他所做的事，米切尔什么也不配得到，我会把这话对他说上一千遍。他什么也不配得到，因为他从那么多珍贵的人身上夺走了太多。”每年的谋杀纪念日，伊芙琳都会请假一天来缅怀凯伦、丹尼尔、阿马拉和卡特里娜。虽然她永远无法原谅比尔·米切尔所做的事，但她拒绝让这让自己变成一个
bitter person. Instead, the experience has taught her what's most important in life, and she focuses on the love she has for her own family. She told Perth Now, I've always taught my kids that everything in life happens for a reason. They even say it now when bad things happen. They tell me that everything in life happens for a reason. It's up to us to learn what that is. The fact that Bill Mitchell has the chance to be freed every three years keeps Evelyn up at night. The killings themselves are never far from her mind. Evelyn has made it clear she will never stop fighting against Mitchell's release, and wishes that there was something in place that would stop other families from having to endure
满腹怨恨的人。相反，这段经历教会了她生命中最重要的是什么，她将注意力集中在对自己家人的爱上。她告诉《珀斯现在》报：“我一直教导我的孩子们，生活中的一切发生都是有原因的。当坏事发生时，他们现在甚至也会这么说。他们告诉我，生活中的一切发生都是有原因的。我们要去了解那是什么。”比尔·米切尔每三年就有一次获释的机会，这一事实让伊芙琳夜不能寐。谋杀案本身也一直在她的脑海里挥之不去。伊芙琳明确表示，她永远不会停止反对米切尔获释，并希望有什么机制能阻止其他家庭再去承受
what she now faces. Yet, she remains steadfast. For Evelyn, the only way this will end is if Mitchell is granted parole, or if she dies, whichever comes first. Appearing on the Nine Networks a current affair program, Evelyn spoke of her sister's killer, quote, You can't call the person an animal, because animals have better decency than what this person has. How can you go in and attack and kill beautiful little baby girls? They're totally innocent. How can you do that? He's a sick, perverted piece of garbage. Why doesn't a woman have a right to say no?
她现在所面临的痛苦。然而，她依然坚定不移。对伊芙琳而言，这一切结束的唯一方式要么是米切尔获得假释，要么就是她离世，两者必居其一。伊芙琳在九号电视台的《时事》节目中谈到她姐姐的凶手时说：“你不能称这个人是动物，因为动物的尊严也比这个人强。你怎么能去袭击并杀害漂亮的小女婴？她们完全是无辜的。你怎么能做出这种事？他是个有病的、变态的垃圾。女人为什么没有说不的权利？”
You can't call the person an animal, because animals have better decency than what this person has. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你不能称这个人是动物，因为动物的尊严也比这个人强。该集节目目前尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。